I was wrong to raise you as a human
i should have prepared you better
you're a viltromite in blood only
well your true education begins now
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
invincible episode 8 finale video there were
so many moments the entire episode was basically
a moment just the way they were building up to the
big reveal so we'll break it all down there was a
whole bunch of easter eggs and they actually just
renewed the show for season two and season three
so there'll be at least two more seasons probably
more than that too because it's actually really
solid if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes obviously
spoiler warning for the episode if you have not
seen it yet but i'll just number these as we
go along and talk about moments and easter eggs
starting with the title of the episode where
i really come from all about mark learning
the truth about where omniman his father nolan
grayson really comes from the series just in
general as you could all probably tell is meant
to be a parody of the superman mythology and the
viltromites are kind of like their versions of
kryptonians but with a really dark twist on it
so because this is an amazon tv show and it's very
dark twist on dc comics also we have to talk about
the boys tv show as well because that's also a
big twist on the justice league in marvel comics
the boys obviously fantastic show we're gonna be
seeing season three i'll be doing videos for that
as well but whereas the boys is more of a parody
of the tropes of traditional superhero comics like
the tropes of the justice league stories and the
dc characters they have a very different explainer
for where superheroes really come from in the
boys universe the difference with invincible is
it is actually much closer to the real mythology
of superman's origin story in the comics and the
other kryptonians in dc comics history so it's
like what if you were superboy and superman was
your father but also what if superman and the
kryptonians were the villains of the story and
the reason why they have mark witness his father
killing the immortal is that he kind of recognizes
what's going on like he first he thinks that
he's been taken over by some alien parasite come
to your senses give me meg my father but then he
explains to them no i'm doing this at my own free
will the funny thing about the immortal too i mean
he seemingly kills him but as his name implies
he is immortal you could spend a whole 30 minute
video just explaining his character's backstory
but basically the idea is that you reassemble his
body correctly eventually he'll heal and he'll
come back to life as he did previously in the
series they also follow that up at the end of the
episode too with cecil bringing him back again but
then omniman starts telling mark the dark truth
about why he came to earth what his secret mission
is that he wasn't previously willing to tell his
mother right away like he said we'll talk later
then flies right through the roof of the house
but she's listening to this entire fight this
entire speech the whole time his monologue so
she learns everything including the real twist
that omniman kind of thinks of her as a pet
i'm gonna live forever so you have to imagine how
that affects the way he perceives relationships
like all these people on earth why do you care
about them so much they'll be dead in the blink
of an eye compared to our lifespan but effectively
the first half of the episode is basically him
punching mark into submission you can't even call
it a fight it's more like a massacre that just
slowly plays out across the planet him just
throwing mark around dragging him around punching
him through the planet to different cities trying
to force him to submit while destroying as much
property as possible like you say that there
was a lot of property destruction during the
dc movies like man of steel during the justice
league movie there were a couple of darker funny
moments too like you kind of feel bad laughing
but it is kind of ridiculous when he punches him
down to the bottom of the ocean and then drags him
back up he goes back through the other side of the
cruise liner instead of just going around it like
he could have gone in any direction flown in any
direction but he decides to go back up through
the cruise liner just because he wants to cause
more damage but while this montage of punching and
violence is happening he kind of glosses over some
of the details of his backstory so mark's father
nolan grayson is really the son of the former
emperor of the viltromite people so mark actually
comes from a royal bloodline technically he is a
viltromite prince it doesn't give him any special
extra powers or anything like that but it does
give him a level of immunity against some special
viruses that are meant to target the viltrumite
people specifically but what happened a long time
ago in their people's history is that nolan's
father the viltromite emperor was assassinated by
someone close to him who usurped the throne then
thragg one of their most powerful viltromites to
ever live got revenge killed the usurper he took
control of their military there was a huge civil
war and then he used that to reform their people's
culture in their ways so when he gets to the
part of his speech where he talks about his race
culling the week out so that only the strongest
remained and it basically cut their population
in half that's what he's referring to after thragg
took control he instituted this policy where you
see them all training against each other to become
the strongest so if it wasn't clear even though
it feels like omniman is unkillable there are
vultromites that are even more powerful than him
which is the thragg character so you have to
imagine that it's a lot like superman fighting
other kryptonians like there would be other
kryptonians who could potentially be stronger
than superman given enough time so more superman
references eventually the vulture my people became
more imperialistic going around conquering the
rest of the universe as he says during his speech
and what they did is they would assign different
voltromites to different planets having them
integrate with people living there but secretly
preparing the planet for full-blown filtramide
invasion the very practical reason why he says
they do things this way playing the long game
instead of just rolling up to a planet and trying
to take it over on the spot is because eventually
they conquered so many planets around the universe
they actually started to run into a manpower
problem where they didn't have enough viltromites
to go to other new planets and conquer new places
also they had problems with rebellions and
uprisings alan the alien played by seth rogen
kind of explains that towards the end of the
episode when he's talking to mark about the
history of his home planet he said the reason
why his home planet was destroyed was because
his people rebelled against the vulture mites so
rather than take the trouble of reconquering them
and using all these resources they just decided
to cut their losses and blew the planet up so
the reason why mark exists is because of that
new program of them interbreeding and creating
more viltromites that way that's what omniman's
whole villain monologue here is about he's trying
to get mark to turn to the dark side join me and
we can rule the universe together very star wars
very apropos because mark hamill has a cameo seen
as the art character the person who makes all the
super suits one of the darker moments during
their fight is when omniman basically tells him
that you don't matter it'll only take another
17 years to replace you implying that he could
just fly off and have another child with another
human woman because obviously he's not going to
go back to his mother but while this is happening
he also clarifies some of their powers their races
abilities so as they get older their aging process
slows even more meaning that theoretically a pure
voltromite could live indefinitely one with pure
blood even mark who's half philtromite he says
will live for thousands of years bare minimum so
this whole mission about him weakening the planet
for invasion is why he killed the guardians at the
end of episode one they were basically like the
invincible series version of the justice league
remember how cecil kept referencing that he tried
to get omniman on several occasions over the years
to join the guardians but he kept refusing and
omniman kind of played it off like i don't need
them i don't need any help he kind of tried to
instill that belief in mark like don't go joining
any teams but mark wound up trying to join the
team team anyway or at least work with them it's
all because omniman always knew that eventually
the guardians would be the first group that cecil
would send after him earth's last line of defense
so he was systematically trying to earth's
defenses to take out every possible weapon they
could use against him and i feel like steven
yoon's performance is invincible as mark was
actually great in the episode you totally buy that
he wouldn't care about the viltromites at all like
i don't care about some race of people that i've
never met before these are all my friends that
you're trying to kill so even though he valiantly
tries to fight him it's hilarious how quickly
omniman shuts him down let's just give you an
idea of how much more powerful omniman is how
unkillable he really is it's all meant to be very
tragic the way this plays out i feel like they
did a great job of selling that during the episode
like i had to sit down for a minute after i watch
this think about my life think about my choices
and one of the other best moments of the episode
is the moment that gives him pause when he has the
flashback just as he's about to finish punching
mark's face in he flashes back to the baseball
game when he was a child in the importance of his
wife's speech like see his happiness becomes your
happiness aren't you happy now watching him and
this sort of reveals that he actually does care
about mark he does care about his wife even though
he says that he doesn't at many times during the
episode like he calls his wife a pet she's more
like a pet to me him sort of having that moment
where he realizes he actually does care about mark
is the only thing that saved his life the only
reason he didn't get smashed into a ball of goo in
the only reason why omniman didn't burn the entire
planet to the ground it's just that he isn't
willing to stray from his mission so to speak
i'll explain the ending of the episode too and
what happens to him next because omniman basically
just takes off into outer space and you don't see
him again but there's a lot of theories that they
have about where he went the thing about omniman 2
is they try to make him a little more sympathetic
like he's not your straight up mustache twirling
villain even though jk simmons is fantastic as
omniman and he does have a mustache that he could
twirl he tries to sell it like oh we're bringing
them into the empire this is a good thing we're
going to give them all this technology all these
medical advancements we're going to stop all war
but all the humans will basically become their
pets so to speak so you'd have to imagine his
personality is kind of like what if superman
were to grow up on krypton being instilled
purely with kryptonian values and then he came
to earth how different would his personality be
he'd probably be more like the eradicator so this
is basically superboy almost being killed by his
father superman like it wasn't about him trying
to win the fight it's more about omniman coming to
the realization that he did care about him even
though there are many times during the series
too they make them seem like they're unkillable
veltromites do have weaknesses that they try to
develop there are ways that they try to fight them
in the future of the series that we'll probably
find out about in season 2 season 3 in their ways
of slowing them down but that's mostly what it is
all these countermeasures are mostly there to just
slow them down not actually kill them but just to
explain what happened to omniman when he flew
off the planet he basically took off into orbit
abandoning his mission to conquer earth that was
given to him by thragg sort of like the military
leader of all veltromites normally they would
punish omniman severely for abandoning his post
so to lessen his sentence what he does is he
immediately decides to go take over a different
planet he basically goes for the easy layup so
maybe we'll see a teaser for that in season two
or season three at some point omniman is still
part of the story but basically he leaves the main
story for a little while because the main story
is all about mark's life is invincible if you
have read the comics please don't post spoilers
for what happens to omniman way later on but he
does come back in a big way eventually then after
the montage of destruction and violence cecil and
his mother arrive to take mark to their special
hospital and after he recovers it's still only
like halfway through the episode basically the
aftermath is just as huge the big reveals in a lot
of the second half of the episode is really just
table setting for season two and season three just
teasing all the big stuff that mark is going to
deal with so probably one of the next big reveals
is when cecil takes them into their special
lab and reveals that special frequency of light
that most humans aren't capable of seeing because
they've been lacing the water this whole time i'm
sure conspiracy theorists will love that but it's
also about what they're doing inside the lab you
like pan around you see all these different scenes
of them testing weapons testing armor and you see
them bringing the immortal back to life he also
has a big speech with alan the alien at the end
where he asks him what are you gonna do next and
they have that huge montage of all the different
story lines and characters that i'll explain in
a second all big teasers for season two but he
says basically finish high school i guess he'll
continue to try and not fail out of high school
for lack of attendance while rushing off every
five seconds to deal with more earth-shattering
catastrophes and supervillains so if you haven't
read the comic book series it's all out there like
the comic book series ended a while ago so you
can actually read the entire story even though the
tv show story is actually a little bit different
robert kirkman also revealed the reason why he's
changing the comic book story a little is because
he just believes that he's a better writer now he
wrote the comic book story when he was in his 20s
he's like i was just wasn't as good of a writer
back then but then amber comes back around on him
so she'll be back in season two they kind of imply
that they getting back together as a couple he's
also got this long-running romance with adam eve
in the comics and without giving away big spoilers
they kind of teased their chemistry during season
one but i'm assuming that they won't get together
till like the end of season two maybe season three
robert kirkman explained that he's got about
seven seasons worth of material just adapting
the comics so i think they'll eventually
get to everything it's just a question of
how much they'll speedrun the comic book story
and what they'll cut out but they do go back to
mark hamill's character have a tag scene with
art i think just because they have mark hamill
like oh man we need to use them in this episode
at least once mark eventually does get a couple
invincible costume changes and they do get into
some multiverse tropes so you see many different
versions of invincible costumes so hopefully
they'll bring mark hamill back in future seasons
then that whole speech that allen the alien goes
out on about them fighting the viltromites is kind
of like them taking their big brute shot calling
their avengers end game so he talks about the
coalition of planets trying to assemble an army
to defeat the vultromites and that's meant to be
their endgame their avengers endgame moment that
they're building up to like in the first avengers
movie thanos shows up in the post credit scene to
let you know that he is the end game of this story
arc the infinity saga this whole final battle for
independence from the viltromites that they're
teasing on invincible that's like the show's
version of end game but the way alan explains
it no one up to this point has ever been powerful
enough to fight the viltromites they're literally
unkillable for the most part i mean one vulture
might could kill another voltromite but for the
most part if you're not a voltromite you have
zero chance against them which is why invincible
is kind of like their new luke skywalker
just to make another mark hamill reference
i guess in this scenario thragg would be kind
of like the show's version of emperor palpatine
we might meet him during season two maybe not till
season three they might wait a while on that but
here are all the scenes that they tease for season
two in that ending montage so they re-arrest the
maulers lock them up this guy with the cast on
his arm was the same guard that they wrecked when
they were escaping these are the flaxsens plotting
to attack earth again they were the aliens using
the time dilation devices from another dimension
omniman had basically traveled to their home world
and obliterated it in the span of a couple weeks
it was actually a really badass scene then you
see doc seismic again from episode 3 controlling
a bunch of magma golems preparing to attack again
you see those parasites that took over mars
spreading and getting even worse they show
you titan again who took over as the boss of the
city after they got rid of his old boss then right
on cue you see battle beast also from the same
episode who almost wound up killing invincible
and probably one of the bigger teasers here is
cecil inspecting the newest upgraded riannamen
drones they're kind of like the show's version of
terminators they just keep iterating making them
more and more powerful as a last resort against
the viltromites when they eventually do show up
and if you didn't know the song that's playing
over this montage is called i hate to tell you
i told you so by the hives very apropos because
it's also meant to be a reference to the plot
of the episode and what's in store for mark next
for invincible so everyone just post your favorite
moment from the episode in the comments below or
from the series in general i'll do more videos for
season two when they start releasing more footage
but it's only going to get crazier things will
only escalate and if you do want to you can go
read the comics right now my next video will be
for that falcon and winter soldier bonus episode
they have a special episode that they're releasing
with a whole bunch of extra footage behind the
scenes stuff it's just like the same episode that
they did for wandavision after the finale so that
video should be up by tonight make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
anything everyone click here for my full falcon
and winter soldier episode 6 finale video and
click here for that brand new captain america 4
movie announcement thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!